demon souls is back this is the game
that started at all and it's being fully
rebuilt from the ground up for
PlayStation 5 forget 60 frames per
second forget 4k this goes so far beyond
what any of us were expecting let me
explain so the footage that you're
seeing right now is mostly reconstructed
cutscene content from the original game
for example this scene with the tower
Knights smashing down his shield look
how closely it resembles the original
the same goes for this fall's idle
cutscene
the storm king cutscene the Reaper enemy
and the flame Locker so what's special
about this is that because these
cutscenes are what plays right before
the boss fights that means that these
visuals are what you can expect to see
when you actually play the game press
screenshots confirm this just look at
these in-game shots I'm gonna try and
compare these places alongside their
original locations and it's staggering
how much effort they've put into
recreating and also expanding these
places but I have to say what have they
done to the fluted armor they're
massacred my boy looking at these screen
shots you can kind of tell that it's not
mostly developed by from software
because this detail is honestly beyond
what from software usually aims for even
when you compare it to recent titles
like secular and I feel like that's
significant because if they're going
this hard at the remakes from a
graphical point of view there's no way
it's going to play as clunky as the
original did so yes we're getting
graphical changes but I also think it's
really likely that we'll be getting
quality of life changes gameplay changes
and possibly even new content let's talk
about that
the first thing that really struck me
from a graphical point of view was the
tower knight footage obviously the
graphics are stellar but more
importantly I have to say the mood here
is significantly different from the
original before this area was grim it
was foggy and oppressive but now the
atmosphere is bold its heroic its
vibrant that's huge when I talk about
how much I love demon souls the first
thing I go to is the atmosphere I think
it has the best atmosphere of any from
software game and they are making
significant changes on that front so for
better or worse honoring the original
atmosphere is clearly not a goal of
theirs right now so the question I have
is do we stand to lose some of demon's
souls oppressive ethereal sort of
atmosphere or are we standing to gain
much more I mean look at the rust
creeping up the tower knight's shield or
the
vines and nature that's overtaking the
castle will this honor the original
vision will it change it completely and
how will that affect the atmosphere but
what if we could get the best of both
worlds before it was removed the
official trailer description actually
had something in it called fractured
mode and no one knows what this is or
was but one thing it could be is a
graphical version of the game that's in
line with the original and this could be
a setting that you could toggle while
you play some remakes do come with this
feature these days what you're seeing on
screen is 60fps 4k footage of the
emulated version on PC and if you could
choose to play a version of the game
that's more like this rather than the
super graphical version I'd be so stoked
for that my god however maybe that's not
what fractured mode is and Sony have now
gone on to say that this information is
outdated and inaccurate so who knows
what fractured mode was or if it will
still be in the game
under a different name the remake is
being handled by Blue Point games who
are one of the most accomplished
developers in the remake seen the most
recent accomplishment was their 2018
remake of the ps2 classic shadows of the
Colossus which was released to stellar
reviews and if anyone can do this game
justice it's them so trust outside of
the gameplay cutscenes this trailer
opens with a callback to the prologue of
the original game even showing some
additional scenes of what looks like the
valley of defilement for those of you
who haven't played in Demon Souls you
play as an unnamed warrior who travels
into boletaria
which is a land rapidly becoming overrun
by soul devouring demons behind every
demon is an Archdemon and behind every
arch demon is the old one itself which
is an ancient being that we kind of see
in this scene where it soars over a
world that's becoming shrouded by fog
now the shot that a lot of people are
speculating about is this one
snowy region that we never get to
explore in-game and you know why
it's because it was cut before release
Demon Souls has six worlds and they're
represented by arch stones in the hub
world but one of these arch tones is
broken so this was originally supposed
to lead to a place called the northern
limit and it was a snowy hinterland at
the very edge of the country's borders
and here you were supposed to explore a
temple now this temple still exists
within the files of the game and if
there is new content being developed
which admittedly is a long shot this is
where we'd be going but I want to talk
more about that at the end of the video
so in my opinion quality of life changes
are very likely to happen quality of
life is a term used to describe minor
updates to the gameplay that have a big
effect on convenience the original Demon
Souls was not convenient by any stretch
of the imagination
every item had a weight and there was a
maximum amount of items you could carry
so you had to do a lot of inventory
management crystal lizards don't respawn
which was a nightmare climbing a ladder
has the slowest animation ever created
and you couldn't consume more than one
soul at once menus were really outdated
and even exiting out of menus too
quickly would cause your character to a
roll which you can imagine was fun did I
mention that gravity sucks too gravity
sucks you generally took very little
full damage in Demon Souls but at a
certain point drop damage just increases
exponentially and your knees just
exploded past this point but beyond this
how much the gameplay changes would
depend on how much from software is
involved and there is a lot they could
change if they had a mind to I would say
the first thing that comes to mind is
omnidirectional rolling since in the
original you could only really roll in a
few directions while you were locked on
that's probably the single biggest thing
they could do to make the game feel
modern and in line with recent titles
next magic is just way too overpowered
in demon souls while I love that magic
in this game can be cast more freely and
I also prefer how you can get mana to
regenerate and I prefer how it's used as
a resource but
the royalty starting class which starts
with magic just puts you on such a
pedestal compared to the other classes
and you carry that advantage with you
through the entire game right up until
the last boss another poorly balanced
thing about Demon Souls is the healing
system so in this game you heal by
consuming grass and there are different
types of grafts that all heal different
amounts it's kind of like blood-borne in
the sense that you have to farm for your
healing items but it's also more extreme
than blood-borne because you can carry
more than 20 healing items and some of
those healing items heal your full
health bar so if you want to you can
just farm powerful healing items and
abuse the hell out of them which is also
a really bad problem in PvP something
like Estus would be so much better but
the most controversial mechanic in Demon
Souls was something called world
tendency and for those who don't know
this was a mechanic whereby the world
itself would respond to your deaths and
also to the deaths of players around you
if you're playing offline then your
world tendency starts at neutral and it
will shift towards white or black
according to the player's actions for
example whenever you do something good
like you kill a boss a dragon or a black
phantom your world tendency will move
towards white and in a white world
tendency your attack power is increased
in soul form enemies a weaker but they
do drop less items in contrast to move
towards a black world tendency you
generally do something bad like dying
out in the world in human form or maybe
you kill human form NPCs in a black
world tendency you're weaker in Soul
form enemies are stronger but they do
drop more Souls and rare items on top of
this special world events will happen
based on your world tendency like locked
doors might open phantoms can appear and
new NPC quest lines can be unlocked it
gets more complicated than that but this
was a really unique interesting system
at the time it was super ambitious but
it has so many flaws
this should go without saying but a
mechanic where your world gets more
difficult the more you die is kind of
[ __ ] up for new players especially and
while some store events are unlocked
with it it's super complicated even to
veteran players and most players will
just play through the game without even
knowing it exists so I would be really
surprised if this mechanics or no
changes but now we're stirring very
close to the idea of new content which
I'm not gonna get my hopes up for but
it's possible as I mentioned earlier
Demon Souls originally had six worlds to
explore but one of them was cut very
early on in development what you're
seeing on screen is what remains of the
northern limit which is explored here by
a content creator named Gibbs who has
done a lot of work patching and
exploring demon souls the cut enemies of
demon souls are likely to belong here as
well so expect a lot of beast men and
Giants as these are some of the
creatures that we never really got to
see as you can tell this was a very
snowy area and while some people are
taking the snowy scene in the remake
trailer as proof that we'll be exploring
this area I do want to remind you guys
that a snowy scene was seen in the
original prologue as well in a week or
so I'll actually have a video going far
more in depth on the broken arch stone
and the land of the giants that
supposedly lies beyond it so subscribe
for that turn on notifications because
we actually know a lot more about the
lore of this place than most people
think and I'm excited to share some new
discoveries with you all funnily enough
the world that you saw in our painted
world poster was actually meant to
depict the land of the giants and also
the broken arch stone so if you
purchased this poster or you want to go
and take a closer look link in the
description of course a new area to
explore would mean new items weapons
armors and demon souls could actually do
with a lot more of these because the
original selection is quite limited so I
can think of two big questions that
remain first what is or what was
fracture
mode is at what I mentioned earlier
where you might be able to revert the
game back to its original graphics or
does it have to do with gameplay or
demon souls actually originally had a
permadeath mode before it was removed
maybe it's that but I'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments on what
fractured mode could be and lastly a
release date I have a bit of a theory on
this so there isn't a release date
currently and you know what else doesn't
have a release date PlayStation 5
therefore I think it's possible that
Demon Souls could be a PS 5 launch title
which would explain why they haven't
mentioned anything the other alternative
is that the game still has a bit more
development to go so maybe it's gonna be
released next year who knows regardless
I'm so excited for this game eight
months ago I made a video on why I
thought Demon Souls deserves a remaster
so go and watch that if you want to know
what made this game so special Demon
Souls just took so many risks as a game
and it's incredibly close to my heart
and it's about time the newer members of
the souls community played this game
because I know like 75% of you haven't
which is a huge shame but I'm excited
for you guys so thank you so much for
watching and see you in the next video
where I actually plan to announce the
next art competition guess what it's
about I shall await then return slayer
of demons I am here for thee in the only
[Music]